i a little self-conscious about saying
this but i think that that uh my former
um co-author and i were the first people
to come up with that idea of vocalism as
a religion in 2014 an essay we published
in all think uh privileges the original
sin we talked about this is a new
religion
but you see
so this is the explanatory mechanism for
why
media literally every institution you
can think of has been captured
well it's the mechanism by which it has
continuously spread yes metastasize is
actually the exact right term it's not
contagion it's metastasized across the
body politic and frankly this is uh
maybe we will
talk a little bit about our mutual
friend james lindsey
but this is why i have a hard time
knowing what to think about where he is
which is that that metastasis is
as far as i can tell and you tell me if
you see it differently
it is capable of
destroying the west and it is not a
terrible stretch to imagine that it
jeopardizes our species in so doing
right that the the the
yeah the world is depending on the west
to succeed oh i see you mean by species
i don't think it's a species threatening
problem i think that there are
too many prophylactics in place in other
countries to prevent that
i don't know how you could think that
frankly because the problem is there are
too many industrial processes on which
we collectively depend
that if we suddenly decide that
you know anybody who holds you know
anybody who subscribes to wrong think is
not entitled to work yeah that those
things will collapse yeah i i know i
don't believe that that's tom friedman's
idea of the flat earth i i don't think
that that's true
the idea that you know like that's why
they're in the theory of the golden
arches for example no two countries have
ever had mcdonald's have gone to war
with themselves into yugoslavia there's
something about trade relations yeah i'm
not making that argument i would argue
i'm making the argument that there are
technological processes on which we
depend
that require smart people to operate
them well you can drive all the smart
people out because they can't stand
being forced to say things they know are
false yeah that those systems will come
apart and when they do it is not just
simply the collapse of western nations
but it is those technological processes
that we are
maintaining
and it is not yeah i'm not saying like
what swift banking systems or what are
you talking about how about the
agriculture okay right the nuclear
reactors require us to maintain
vigilance right we have a problem
lasts for tens of thousands arguably
hundreds of thousands of years that we
have set in motion and we don't have a
mechanism for getting stupid people to
maintain it okay so let me throw this
out to you um
[Music]
i can't believe i'm going to admit this
on your podcast but i'll admit this when
we first had this idea of of um wokism
as a religion
we tossed around the idea
of
um infecting entire cultures with it
enemies of the united states north korea
iran i wouldn't put china as an enemy
you you were thinking of using it as an
offensive weapon yeah but we didn't know
how to deploy it right we just didn't
know how to deploy somebody experience
social justice yeah they did they did
they did beat us to it it's
spread on its own
i well i don't know i don't know that i
don't know how we rule out that this
the fact that we are attacking
everything that works yeah that we are
uninventing all of the things on which
the west is based correct
looks to me beyond what a pathology
right so let's i want you to repeat that
because that's so important we are what
did you say uninventing we are
uninventing all of the mechanisms in
which the west is based that is exactly
the issue
yep exactly right but the point the
point that i would make is
if we were neglecting
the things that allow the west to work i
could say okay that's
folly the fact that we are actively
going after everything that works
suggests enemy action now i don't know
oh it's our enemies oh okay so faizal
al-mutar uh
one very very very close friend of mine
he told me that the chinese government
and the russians i think he told me this
last year i can text him and ask him at
the end of the podcast we put in the
youtube description if you want uh and
qatar and oman etc have
english language stations that push blm
crt etc to undermine the foundations of
our society i mean it's brilliant you
can do without throwing a bomb you don't
need a bunch like the old star trek
episode where the people walk into the
right yeah the question is
wokism
is destructive of the fabric of the west
unquestionably
and far
less in fact it's even intentionally
disruptive well that's what i'm arguing
right i i'm not arguing that i know this
to be true but i'm already i'm arguing
that i know that to be true but we would
be crazy
not to wonder there are look there are a
lot of people not to wonder why i finish
the sentence not to wonder what if our
antagonists in the world our competitors
we're not seeding this into our culture
oh yeah oh we're told that's not that's
what there's no question that they are i
mean
there is a question well i've seen some
of the shows the blm stuff coming out
but go ahead um
if
the bolsheviks
introduce communism
right
and i think oh
that's gonna that's gonna mess up the
russians and the russians are my
competitors so i'm going to you know i'm
going to add some communist propaganda
that's not me taking down
russia correct right that's me
amplifying correct the question is did
this woke revolution come from somewhere
did somebody have a meeting and say look
oh you're talking about the the genesis
beyond foucault dario leotard you're
talking about the way that was i'm
saying i don't want to assume that i
know why the west is deliberately it
would seem tearing apart every
functional structure and replacing it
with a fairy tale right but i don't even
think they're replacing it with that's
way too much what are they replacing it
with chass i mean what are they
replacing that's a fairy tale that
people that you have a dystopian one but
okay i'll guess
the idea that you can get rid of the
police and civilization will get better
is a fairy tale it's [ __ ] as fairy
tales tend to be
so my point is look
i don't know if wokism is
organic in its inception yeah and some
enemy said hey
look at this if we can get the west to
embrace this stuff we won't have to fire
a shot yeah that's possible or it's
possible that it came from some enemy to
begin with i don't know or maybe it's
not possible yeah i don't that it's uh
i mean this look yeah it's how possible
i it's always possible
i know it's being funded by i don't want
to go so far as to say enemy regimes but
i guess in the case of of russia it is
an enemy regime
we know that this is being funded right
now i don't know in terms of your
comment about the genesis i don't really
know i mean it's
a built-in divisive
pitting people genders against each
other pitting races against each other
here's here's the unfortunate problem
yeah okay
religion is not a mind virus it's an
adaptation okay yeah you gave a great
lecture on my class about that so
i don't think this is logically in doubt
i think it's very difficult for people
to swallow because they for a long time
have been
rewarded for simply pointing out the
folly of much of the analytical content
surrounding religion
but that's not really the point what
makes it an adaptation is the behavioral
prescriptions and those are not modern
those are behavioral prescriptions for a
world we don't live in anymore but
nonetheless the point is the
term mind virus
has been polluted
by
the new atheists using it incorrectly
for things to which it doesn't apply
however
locism
is
a mind virus right it will not function
as an adaptation what will happen to it
over time
just
well totally total destruction it will
self-destruct it has to it
nothing else is possible because it has
no analytical content yeah not only that
so so let's delve into that if you don't
want to
i am
positive that this is a
i don't know when the expiration date is
every time i so so i've been screaming
about this since
2012.
um
[Music]
and it's
frankly it's very frustrating to me i
don't know when the expiration date is
um i see how quickly it's go so so i
used to think okay
well it's in philosophy now
equity
you know hiring people just because they
have certain immutable physical
characteristics as thomas sewell said if
you want diversity and put some
republicans in the sociology department
um
so
i've watched this
contain i've watched this this
mine mine virus and i used to think okay
well they they just think philosophy is
not important and then it went from that
to medicine
it went for i think it was american
airlines has diversity requirements
among pilots
like pilots holy [ __ ]
um and clearly nobody's gonna say that
those things aren't important
even if it won it would lose correct
because in the end that's absol that's a
great point if if if the coalition of
the woke
won all the power and had the ability to
architect the world that it claims it
wants a
it does not have enough competence to
make anything work but even more
troubling as peterson's talked about
that yeah is the fact that the various
different constituents of the coalition
would destroy each other right so it's
self-unstable there's no question
there's there's no there there
right
so we know that
i don't think it matters when the only
question is are we going to let it go to
fruition or are we going to stop it
before it destroys everything in its
path which is what it's doing and that's
where we are right those of us who both
understand the problem with it and are
willing to say it out loud
and willing to
reap the consequences of that right and
you know they're arbitrary the thing
obviously detests us and you know lost
for understandable friendship as a lost
relationships is a big part of that yeah
um but that i mean the process is worse
than we know yeah i mean at the risk of
uh
making things difficult for us to parse
what i saw happen with standard
wokeness happened with kovid too
i saw a coveted wokeness and i and
frankly i still see it right our entire
medical establishment
is pretending to know things that not
only does it not know but that aren't
true
and
i don't know what you do when suddenly
all of your doctors are persuaded of
fiction are effectively embracing
uh a cult and you know health is in the
balance i don't know what you do but
that's where we are and that suggests
something even more frightening which is
that the
disconnect between
the minds of intelligent people and
reason
is potentially independent of topic
yeah that's what i think we came up with
that's the substitution hypothesis that
people just have to believe something
and then the brain is the hardware and
the content is just plugged in
well i don't think that that's generally
true but i think that the dysfunction
that we are seeing
is happening across domains and well
that's certainly
and the thing that spooks me the most is
that some of the people who i thought
were
most eloquent in spelling out what was
wrong with the original version of
wokeness
missed the boat on covet
i don't know what to do with that people
who had the immunity
to woke thinking when the topic was
you know race and gender
didn't have what it took when it came so
i feel viruses i feel the same way about
the new atheist and the skeptic movement
the same people who had the tools
and it really is true that the tools are
the same you know what is your evidence
how do you weigh the evidence what is
the argument against it make it you can
do you know what tim van gelder does
argument mapping what have you
the tools are the same but
the the tremendous irony is that
from the skeptical movement and the
atheist movement
emerged new movements of people who
claimed to be skeptics and atheists who
themselves were the most dogmatic
religious people you would ever meet
right like foot soldiers of these
movements that are not supposed to have
foot soldiers yes and then you know i i
would point this out to folks and
uh on i will say a difference is unlike
traditional religious people who say yes
i'm religious
woke people won't say they're religious
they don't they haven't
it hasn't um that idea
hasn't become
i don't know if acceptable or understood
or mainstream i don't know what the word
is but they won't say yes i'm religious
i'm i'm the woke religion or the
critical social justice religion i mean
in fact what they do is they claim the
mantle of science which is upside down
and back that's
yeah you know um and that's right so
yeah
if i find that we are in the place that
we always end up when people uh
a viewer and my mindset on this get
together which is that we talk ourselves
blue in the face
trying to say look
this is not
difficult to understand no it's not
difficult to understand at all dangerous
it's frightening right but it's not hard
to see it the problem is that despite
the fact that it's not hard to see it
most do not
[Music]